[موسيقى] أجنبية
كبيرة في يوم الجمعة الأسود هذا بالنسبة لمعظم بائعي التجزئة ،
إنه وقت مناسب أو استراحة من العام ، ولكن
مع قلق المستهلكين في جميع أنحاء العالم بشأن
ارتفاع الأسعار ، فقد يكون موسم العطلات هذا
بمثابة فساد للبيع بالتجزئة ، فلنذهب إلى المكان
الذي بدأت فيه الجمعة السوداء بالولايات
المتحدة ، وهذا هو  كم
ارتفعت وجبة عيد الشكر على مدار
العام الماضي الديك الرومي بمقدار الربع
والمشكلة التي لدينا هي أن الأسعار ليست مجرد
ارتفاع في الأجور لا يرتفع كثيرًا ،
لذا ألق نظرة على هذا الرسم البياني من الولايات المتحدة
مرة أخرى  يمكنك أن ترى كيف ترتفع الأسعار
أعلى بكثير من معدل زيادات الأجور
وهذا يعني ببساطة أننا لا نستطيع
شراء الكثير من الأشياء ، دعنا نسمع من
محلل تجزئة هو رئيس
Shopify وهذه هي الطريقة التي يرى بها يوم الجمعة الأسود.
كنت ترى بالفعل أرقامًا
مرتفعة قليلاً عن العام الماضي استنادًا إلى
مبيعات ذروة عيد الشكر في الدقيقة وأعتقد
أنك تعرف أحد العناصر
الرئيسية الأخرى التي تعرفها من
هذا الموسم هو يوم الجمعة الأسود من
ديسمبر  لم تعد الفترة مجرد
عطلة نهاية أسبوع ، لقد أصبحت حقًا
موسمًا وأعتقد أن الكثير من المستهلكين كانوا
يتسوقون مبكرًا ويبحثون عن
خصومات ، لكن الاتجاه الرئيسي هنا هو
القصد الذي نشهده حقًا أن
المستهلكين يشترون
بطريقة مقصودة للغاية يريدون  يشترون من
العلامات التجارية المفضلة لديهم ، إنهم يريدون
الحصول على خصومات لكنهم يريدون دعم
ماركاتهم المفضلة ويريدون الشراء مباشرة قدر الإمكان ، دعونا نتحدث عن إسكات أليسون ،
إنها تتذوق تلك الحمى كما
كانت عادةً في البداية
يوم الجمعة الأسود في متجر Macy's في
نيويورك ، ما الذي تجده بعد ذلك ما
هي العلامات المبكرة أليسون
ماكس أعتقد أن روح العطلة على الأقل
روح التسوق لا تزال تعمل
هنا على الأقل هنا في
متجر Macy's الشهير في هيرالد سكوير
هنا في مدينة نيويورك ، أنت تعلم أن بضع
مئات من الأشخاص كانوا ينتظرون في طابور
خارج المتجر قبل أن تفتح الأبواب ،
كان الظلام باردًا وكان الجو باردًا
وانتظروا  فتحت أبواب الخراطيم للهتافات
وبدا الجميع متحمسين للحضور
وإنفاق أموالهم ، وذهبت للتحدث مع
بعض هؤلاء المتسوقين بسبب
تضخم الفيل في الغرفة ،
كيف ستتعامل مع التكاليف المرتفعة
وشراء كل هذه الهدايا التي طلبتها  لهم وما
زالوا إيجابيين بشكل عام ،
أخبرني الكثيرون أنهم ملتزمون
بميزانياتهم أنهم يبحثون عن خصومات
وهذا هو سبب قدومهم مبكرًا اليوم
علامات مثل هذا الخصم 60 على
السعر الأصلي وهذا هو الشيء
الذي يجذب الناس إلى المتاجر  لمحاولة
الحصول على تلك الصفقات للحصول على تلك الخصومات
لأنك تعلم أنهم يديرون
تكلفة أعلى لكل شيء ويحاولون
الحصول على أكبر عدد ممكن من الهدايا لمحاولة الحفاظ على هذا
السحر على قيد الحياة خلال موسم الأعياد ،
لذا فهم جميعًا يتسوقون ويخرجون
يحاولون شراء الأشياء ولكن هل
ينفقون القدر الذي سمعته أنك تعرف
أنهم لا يشترون على نطاق واسع
أنهم أكثر إدراكًا ،
نعم لقد تحدثت مع اثنين من
الاقتصاديين الذين أخبروني أنك تعرف
ما الذي تريده  من الواضح أن
الأرقام بالدولار سترتفع ، لذا فإن
الأرقام التي نحصل عليها من الاتحاد الوطني
للبيع بالتجزئة هي أن الإنفاق
سيزيد بنحو ثمانية بالمائة مقارنة
بأرقام العام الماضي مضيفة ما يصل إلى حوالي
940 إلى 960 مليار دولار في
إنفاق العطلات I  أتحدث عن شهري نوفمبر
وديسمبر لكن الاقتصاديين يقولون لي
أنه عندما تضع التضخم في الاعتبار
وأنت تعلم أن هذا أعلى من الدولارات ولكن
عندما تضع في الاعتبار التضخم ،
فأنت تعلم في الواقع أن الناس لا
ينفقون الكثير على أشياء كثيرة أو لا يفعلون ذلك
شراء العديد من الأشياء لأنهم
ينفقون أكثر على الأشياء
التي يشترونها ولكن الخبير الاقتصادي
يقول على الرغم من أننا لن
نرى إنفاق الرياضيات الذي رأيناه
العام الماضي والذي كان في الواقع خارجًا عن
المألوف.  سنشهد
انخفاضًا كبيرًا أيضًا ، لذا
أوضح الاقتصاديون لي أنه كان
نوعًا ما نعود إلى الوضع الطبيعي
على الرغم من أن الإنفاق هذا العام بمجرد
ضبط التضخم ثابتًا  لا تزال
على طول المنطقة العادية ،
خاصة في الوقت الذي نشهد فيه
تضخمًا قياسيًا مرتفعًا هنا في الولايات
المتحدة ، فنحن نعرف مقدار الضغط الذي يتعرض له
تجار التجزئة الذين يحتاجون حقًا
لجعل هذا الموسم يعمل ، أليس كذلك
لأننا  لقد دخلنا في ركود في كثير من
أنحاء العالم بالفعل ، العالم الغربي
هم المتسوقون الأذكياء الذين سيؤجلون
فعلاً أه لأن المبيعات
المحتملة بعد عيد الميلاد
ستكون أكثر إثارة للانتباه
لأن تجار التجزئة سيكونون يائسين
للتخلص  من المخزون المتبقي بعد
هذا الجزء من الموسم
الذي تعرفه ، أعتقد
أن شهرًا واحدًا ليس في شهر
نوفمبر ، لذلك أعتقد أن الخصومات
قد بدأت في وقت سابق وأشعر
أنها ستستمر في وقت متأخر
من الموسم ، لذا أعتقد نعم ، تجار التجزئة
لديهم الكثير لمواجهته ، لا يزال لديهم
الزيادة المرغوبة في المخزون الذي يحتاجون
إليه للتخلص من أرففهم وفي نفس
الوقت لديهم حالة من عدم اليقين بشأن
ما سيحدث في الاقتصاد الأمريكي
الاقتصاد العالمي في العام المقبل ،
كما تعلم ، سمعنا الاقتصاديين بعد
الاقتصاديين بعد المحللين الذين
توقعوا حدوث ركود ،
فأنت تعرف على الأقل الاقتصاد العالمي إن
لم يكن الاقتصاد الأمريكي وحده ، لذا أعتقد في
هذه المرحلة أن تجار التجزئة يحاولون حقًا
لتقديم هذه الخصومات لجذب
المستهلكين وحملهم على إنفاق ليس
أليسون كاوستيك في مستودع Macy's ، شكرًا
لك على انضمامك إلينا